last year I released my first book it
was called Wu's wonderful world of maths
and it was all about how mathematics is
woven into the fabric of reality all
around us sometimes in some really
surprising and hidden ways really happy
to say that after almost a year of the
book being out it's been so popular and
well received that's been picked up for
release in the United States so it's
being released as it's a number phille
world different title same book but I'm
really excited that because of the
experiment who are publishing it in the
u.s. you can get this at Amazon all over
the world it can get shipped and I'm
really excited for it to get out the
subtitle is how math is hiding
everywhere from the crown of a tree to
the sound of a sine wave and the release
date is September 3rd so if you're
interested in getting a copy then head
to the experiments website I've popped a
link in the description or if you've got
an Amazon account you can go straight
there and search for it's a number
phille world it's got the same beautiful
design in there from Alyssa Donato who
put all of the illustrations and colors
and everything together and I hope lots
of you get to have a read and enjoy it
and see all the ways that mathematics
for truly is hiding everywhere around us
see you guys